sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden diese anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
nur ein fernes echo hallt noch von den
menschen die hier einst lebten und
arbeiteten
was bleibt sind offene fragen und
ungelöste rätsel
warum endete dieses prestige projekt im
sperrgebiet von tschernobyl als rostige
ruinen
hätte dieser starken oz zum ausbruch des
dritten weltkriegs führen kann
150 meter hoch und hunderte meter lang
noch und die leistung ist dieselbe wie
bei jedem computer der 70er jahre
nämlich winzig ein fehler und es bricht
der dritte weltkrieg aus
[Musik]
nikola teslas revolutionärer
transformator auf long island waren
seine träume von der grenzenlosen
energieversorgung realistisch
[Musik]
sein ziel war es offenbar drahtlose
energieübertragung und stromversorgung
zu ermöglichen denn die tesla spule
erzeugt und überträgt funkwellen
[Musik]
die imposante schaltwarte im herzen
dieses über 100 jahre alten kraftwerks
in ungarn zeugt vom glauben elektrizität
würde eine neue und bessere welt
erschaffen
es war praktisch ein blick in die
zukunft das sollte der bevölkerung und
der ganzen welt zeigen wie
fortschrittlich mann war und dass ein
neues zeitalter an brach
[Musik]
und ein brillanter konstrukteur geriet
in vergessenheit obwohl seine erfindung
dazu bei trug einige der
bemerkenswertesten
bauwerke der welt zu erschaffen
[Musik]
ein kunstwerk ein meisterwerk der
ingenieurskunst und der mathematik
[Musik]
elektrizität versetzte die menschheit
jahrhundertelang in staunen
ende des 19 jahrhunderts entdeckten
wissenschaftler einen weg sie nicht nur
zu erzeugen sondern auch zu nutzen
dadurch wurde das leben auf der erde für
immer verändert
[Musik]
in der ukraine steht einer der
außergewöhnlichsten elektrischen anlagen
die je errichtet wurden
ein riesiges gitterwerk aus stahlträgern
und kabeln bis auf das recht der staaten
im wind herrscht völlige stille
im kalten krieg machte dieser koloss
rund um den globus von sich hören denn
er erzeugte den sogenannten wood becker
die anlage wirkt postapokalyptische wie
ein filmset man kann sich james bond
oder bruce willis dort vorstellen die
unheimliche stille macht den ort zum
perfekten set für einen film über eine
zivilisation auf dem mars es ist echt
schräg
das buga über horizont radarsystem
erstreckt sich auf gut 700 metern länge
und fragt 150 meter in die höhe es
entstand während des kalten kriegs aber
welche rolle spielte es in dieser zeit
[Musik]
die grundidee des über horizont radars
stammt aus den späten vierziger jahren
davor boten die amerikaner die so
genannte bist in early morning line die
aus dutzenden von radarstationen im
hohen norden und nordosten kanadas
bestand
dabei handelt es sich um sicht
verbindungs radarstationen selbst wenn
man die auf einen berggipfel stellte
hatten sie bestenfalls eine reichweite
von etwas mehr als 100 kilometer
über horizont radarsystem erfassten
hingegen an gebiet von tausenden
kilometern
die die anlage war auf dem neuesten
stand der technik und sollte sich die
ionosphäre zunutze machen die oberste
schicht der erdatmosphäre
man muss bedenken dass die erde
natürlich gekrümmt ist was die
reichweite der ausgesendeten funkwellen
einschränkt sie endet praktisch am
horizont
will man das ändern muss man die welle
quasi bieten damit sie der erdkrümmung
folgt das lässt sich zb über die
ionosphäre erreichen die niedrig
frequenzen vom radar reflektiert so dass
die bellen praktisch abprallen und sich
so weiter ausbreiten können
zum glück errechnen computer die nötigen
frequenz änderungen um die signale von
der ionosphäre zurück zur erde zu werfen
um die reflektierten radar signale
nutzen zu können braucht man natürlich
einen enormen sender und einen enormen
empfänger
selbst die modernsten über horizont
anlagen fallen nicht kleiner aus das
sind riesige gerät
[Musik]
mit der fähigkeit herannahen der raketen
aufzuspüren würden die anlagen die
frontlinie in einem eventuellen
zukünftigen krieg bilden aber
würden sie funktionieren
es ist nicht sicher wie gut sie
funktionieren vor allem da wir
inzwischen mehr über die ionosphäre
wissen es wäre unvermeidlich dass eine
art schmier effekt auftreten würde denn
die biosphäre ist nicht völlig ebenmäßig
es gibt abweichungen
im gegensatz zum normalen radar ist es
schwierig zu erfassen woher ein signal
kommt und wie weit es genau entfernt ist
denn es könnte von verschiedensten
stellen reflektiert worden sein
die sowjets wussten dass eine atomrakete
sie innerhalb von minuten erreichen
würde es war also entscheidend
eingehende signale schnell und präzise
auszuwerten ein fehler könnte zur
katastrophe führen
bei so etwas muss man immer den
menschlichen faktor berücksichtigen das
gilt leider auch für die brillantesten
wissenschaftler unser gehirn ist darauf
gepolt muster zu erkennen auch wenn es
gar keine gibt man könnte also dinge
sehen oder für real halten wenn man
angespannt ist wie zb zu zeiten des
kalten krieges die leute waren
angespannt und wollten unbedingt ein
frühwarnsystem da gab es womöglich eine
menge warnsignale
[Musik]
der wood pecker belegt eindrücklich dass
größer nicht unbedingt besser ist 150
meter hoch und hunderte meter lang und
die computerleistung ist dieselbe wie
bei jedem computer der 70er jahre
nämlich witzig die daten müssen also von
einem menschen interpretiert werden und
der ist nun mal fehler wenn er sich für
tot und glaubt die abweichung sei durch
eine herannahende rakete verursacht
worden und nicht durch einen vogel
bricht der dritte weltkrieg aus
wie bei allen einrichtungen dieser art
unterlagen bau und betrieb von dougga
strengster geheimhaltung
aber die anlage verriet sich über ein
unverwechselbares geräusch das ihr auch
ihren spitznamen einbrachte
[Musik]
das russische radar wurde als hohe
becker also als schlecht bezeichnet man
hörte ein
die radar signale verursachten
störgeräusche auf verschiedensten
zivilen standard frequenzen da und auch
denen für den flug funk
sie mussten einige frequenzen ändern
weil es international so viele
beschwerden gab
das klopfen das wort paka ging weiter
bis 1986 der standort der buga anlage
war sorgfältig ausgewählt worden damit
sie auf die unerschöpflichen strom
ressourcen zurückgreifen konnte die vom
nahe gelegenen atomkraftwerk tschernobyl
erzeugt worden
becker stammt aus den 70er jahren und
war in den 80ern noch in betrieb
manche glauben sein energiebedarf und
die signale die er aussendet hätten die
tschernobyl katastrophe verursacht aber
das ist reine spekulation
als am 26 april 1986 reaktor nummer 4
des atomkraftwerks explodiert werden
riesige landstriche radioaktiv verseucht
der gesamte duca komplex und die
unterbringung für rund 1000 leiharbeiter
werden praktisch über nacht geräumt aber
mancher war überzeugt der ruth becker
sei der katastrophe nicht etwa zum opfer
gefallen sondern habe sie ausgelöst
der rat pack erfasst den kalten krieg
eigentlich ganz gut zusammen damals
konnten technischer und technologischer
fortschritt nicht schnell genug gehen es
entstanden riesige furchteinflößende
bauten aber wenn es darauf ankam wurde
nichts davon je wirklich eingesetzt
und jetzt rostet das ding mitten im
sperrgebiet von tschernobyl vor sich hin
vielleicht ist es das was vom bäcker
bleibt wenn wir dieses ungetüm ansehen
zum glück kam das nie zum einsatz ein
korb es wissen erwischt
jetzt steht die einst mächtige anlage
verlassen in den ukrainischen wäldern
eine verfallende erinnerung an die angst
vor einem atomkrieg der abriss wäre zu
teuer eine wiederinbetriebnahme um
denkbar
[Musik]
überall auf der welt zeugen
bemerkenswerte relikte von einer
vergangenen zeit so wie dieser anlage
aus dem kalten krieg verborgen in den
wäldern von istra westlich von moskau
ein kleiner aber äußerst befremdlich
er wirkt als sei er aus einem
science-fiction-film aber tatsächlich
ist er ein elektrischer generator
allerdings stellte der marx generator
seine rivalen in sachen energieerzeugung
mühelos in den schatten
er konnte zum beispiel einen blitz mit
derart hoher spannung erzeugen dass sie
in etwa der gesamtleistung an der
kraftwerke russlands entsprachen aber
zu welchem zweck
in den siebziger jahren verfügten ost
und west über zu ausgeglichene
atomwaffenarsenale als dass eine der
supermächte den ersten schlag hätte
riskieren wollen
also suchte die sowjetunion nach anderen
möglichkeiten um us-raketen
auszuschalten
[Musik]
beide seiten setzen auf verschiedene
verteidigungssysteme die usa wussten um
die raketentechnik der sowjets und die
sowjets wussten um die waffentechnik der
usa
eine begleiterscheinung von atomwaffen
explosionen ist dass dabei unter
umständen ein enormer
elektromagnetischer impuls kurz emp
entsteht der jegliche elektronik außer
gefecht setzen kann auch raketen
lenksysteme
blitze erzeugen ebenfalls einen emp
sowjetische wissenschaftler waren
überzeugt wenn es ihnen gelänge eine
maschine zu bauen die die zerstörerische
kraft von blitzen nutzte könnten sie das
raketenarsenal der usa lahm legen
die wohl schlagkräftigste warf der usa
gegen die sowjetunion waren
marschflugkörper in die flogen dicht
über dem boden und ließen sich nur
schwer parada aufspüren
es galt jedenfalls für das radar an den
frühwarnsystemen der 70er jahre
die technologie hinter der blitz
maschine geht auf den im 19 jahrhundert
entwickelten elektrischen generator
beziehungsweise die spule
zurückspulen sind bestens geeignet um
funkwellen oder auch andere
elektromagnetische wellen zu erzeugen
und auszusenden dabei geht es natürlich
um energie man verwandelte elektrische
in elektromagnetische energie die man
dann übertragen konnte
in den 20er jahren wurden die bemühungen
elektromagnetische energie zu erzeugen
vom deutschen ingenieur erwin otto marx
sowie dem russischen physiker wladimir
ag fortgeführt unter strengster
geheimhaltung entwickelten sowjetische
wissenschaftler ihre theorien zum bau
einer maschine die sie marx bzw kdf marx
generator landen
[Musik]
diese elektrischen und magnetischen ich
nenne es mal zuckungen nutzbar machen zu
können hat die welt verändert
die maschine funktioniert genau wie ein
blitz flugzeugpiloten werden angewiesen
mindestens 30 kilometer abstand zu
gewitterwolken zu halten weil in den
wolken starke elektrische felder
bestehen und blitze durch ein flugzeug
gehen können dabei kann eine emp die
gesamte elektronik der maschine
lahmlegen
das gerät konnte einen beeindruckenden
150 meter langen blitz erzeugen
allerdings nur für 100 mikrosekunden
der nächste schritt wäre den künstlichen
blitz auch kontrollieren zu können aber
der generator verbrauchte enorm viel
energie und war sehr teuer im betrieb
inzwischen war auch klar geworden dass
die usa ihre eigenen emp versuche
durchführten und die udssr im kriegsfall
keinen technologischen vorteil mehr
hätte
nach 1989 zu viel die sowjetunion und es
fehlte schlicht an geldern um den marx
generator zu betreiben
was einst eine mächtige waffe sein
sollte rostet im wald von istra vor sich
hin
ein weiterer revolutionärer
elektromagnetischer generator kommt aus
den usa genauer worden liv auf long
island in dieser ländlichen gegend
östlich von new york verbergen sich die
überreste eines eindrucksvollen plans
das leben auf der erde zu
revolutionieren
hier sollte ein powercenter für den
gesamten planeten entstehen in form
eines holz traums dem sogenannten wurden
cliff trauer aber
hätte sich dieser plan jemals umsetzen
lassen und welcher geheimnisvolle
fanatische tüftler steckte dahinter
elektrizität ist heute eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts war sie der
letzte schrei sie steckte voller wunder
und galt als allheilmittel mit
grenzenlosem potenzial
zu dieser zeit betrachtete man strom und
elektrizität fast wie eine art von
zauberkraft es gab große show
vorführungen um dafür zu werben und
wissenschaftler wurden praktisch wie
magier behandelt
[Musik]
heute steht in worten griff nur noch ein
halb verfallenes laborgebäude
aus aller welt kommen interessierte
besucher um durch die feuchten flure zu
schreiten und zu erforschen was hier
einst geschah
in den anfangsjahren des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts gab es reichlich gerüchte
über mysteriöse experimente seltsam
blitzende lichter und den einsiedler
genie halb verrückter wissenschaftler
der hier arbeitet
sein name nikola tesla
[Musik]
mehr budget ist mit bild des tesla
science center at worden griff und hat
keinen zweifel daran dass tesla city in
das potenzial hatten die welt zu
verändern
ein außergewöhnlicher mann er lebte sehr
zurückgezogen
arbeitete ununterbrochen und war ein
begeisterter erfinder ich glaube er
wollte die welt verbessern und zum wohl
der gesamten menschheit beitragen
[Musik]
das ausmaß einer vision wurde anhand
seines vorhabens in worten griff
deutlich dafür musste er eine völlig
neue art von anlage erbauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier stand damals der tesla turm 1 57
meter hohe bau aus holzbalken mit einer
großen runden kupfer halbkugel an der
spitze die als kondensator spannung
speichern sollte
tesla wollte die kuppel soweit aufladen
wie nur möglich mit millionen von vault
bis er ihre kapazität sprengen und sie
blitze schleudern würde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieser einzigartige aufbau war teslas
bekannteste erfindung und kam in
dutzenden experimenten zum einsatz er
sollte elektrizität direkt in die erde
leiten zu einer speziellen
unterirdischen kammern und von dort aus
durch tunnel in die erdkruste
[Applaus]
sein ziel war es offenbar drahtlose
energieübertragung und stromversorgung
zu ermöglichen denn die tesla spule
erzeugt und überträgt funkwellen und
auch jede andere form
elektromagnetischer wellen
er wollte innerhalb der erdkruste eine
stehende welle aus elektrische energie
erzeugen eine stehende welle muss man
sich wie ein seil vorstellen dass man in
perfekte wellenbewegungen versetzt sie
bewegt sich nicht
rund um die erde gebe es dann diese
scheitel und tal punkte elektrischer
spannung und daraus könnte man strom
abzapfen oder auch die welle so anpassen
dass sie informationen transportiert
diese vision der stromerzeugung und
-verteilung das haben wir übernommen
wenn auch vielleicht nicht direkt von
tesla aber das war der anstoß um die
welt zu verändern und wir haben es
erreicht
aber teslas pläne für wurden cliff
stießen auf skepsis
mit der entscheidung bei seinem riesigen
transformator auf wechsel statt auf
gleichspannung zu setzen wurde er zum
konkurrenten eines anderen wichtigen
erfinders
thomas edison
[Musik]
dessen bevorzugte gleichspannung und
testung setzte auf seine wechselspannung
sie waren erbitterte rivalen zwischen
den beiden herrschte praktisch krieg
wissen konnte sich einfach besser
verkaufen als tesla der sehr oft die
wissenschaft fixiert war und auf seine
vision wie wir die welt verändern
könnten was wir letztlich auch getan
haben
aber fakt war dass wechselspannung sehr
viel besser dafür geeignet ist strom zu
übertragen als gleichspannung
gleichspannung kommt heutzutage
praktisch nur noch in batterien zum
einsatz für kraftwerke ist es sehr viel
einfacher große strommengen als wechsel
spannung zu erzeugen und sie per
leitungen zu übertragen schon tesla
setzte sich mit dem auseinander was wir
jetzt zu entwickeln versuchen nämlich
ratlosen strom
tesla stand sich selbst im weg aufgrund
seiner geheimnisvollen experimente und
seines obsessiven verhaltens wurde er
von vielen als sonderling wahrgenommen
[Musik]
dessen verbündete ihn erhielt
schauvorführungen ab um die gefahren der
wechselspannung zu demonstrieren und
tötete dabei elefanten durch
stromschläge damit die leute schockiert
sagten lieber gleichspannung die ist
sicher
tesla verfiel in depressionen er wurde
krank und starb in armut nach seinem tod
stellte sich dann heraus dass er recht
gehabt hatte er war mit der
wechselspannung auf dem richtigen weg
und fand womöglich sogar den funk noch
bevor es marconi gelangen leider wurde
tesla zu lebzeiten nicht die anerkennung
zuteil die er verdient hätte
[Musik]
das ist es was hauptfinanzier jp morgan
aus dem worten griff projekt zurückzog
blieb ihm nichts anderes übrig als das
gesamte unternehmen aufzugeben
selbst der riesige tor musste abgerissen
werden übrig blieb nichts als das
achteckige fundament
[Musik]
bedauerlicherweise wurde das worden clip
projekt mittendrin abgebrochen weil
angeblich die finanzierung zusammenbrach
ernsthaft der bank jp morgan unterstützt
dich und der hat kein geld oder hat es
damit zu tun dass tesla an kostenloser
energie arbeitet mit der niemand geld
verdienen kann das sollte man sich
vielleicht genauer ansehen
[Musik]
heute verfolgen einige leidenschaftliche
anhänger von teslas ideen seinen worten
griff traum in dubiosen
forschungslaboren auf der ganzen welt
weiter
aber die möglichkeit grenzenlose energie
hat auch schattenseiten
tesla selbst wies darauf hin dass sich
mit hilfe von energie eine superwaffe
entwickeln ließen
und in den 80er jahren führte die us
airforce eine reihe von versuchen durch
um künstliche blitze zu erschaffen code
namen project tesla
die sowjetische marx maschine an ihrem
abgelegenen standort im wald diente den
selben zweck
noch ist nicht klar ob teslas vision von
der zukunft der elektrizität eintreffen
wird im guten wie im schlechten
[Musik]
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
schossen elektrizitätswerke rund um die
welt wie pilze aus dem boden in kehlen
füllt einem stadtteil der ungarischen
hauptstadt budapest steht eines der
ältesten und wohl schönsten kraftwerke
der welt
[Musik]
als es im juni 1914 in betrieb ging war
das kraftwerk ihlenfeld ein
musterbeispiel tten effizienz und
leistung
heute ist die energieerzeugung ein
grundlegende industrieller vorgang und
kraftwerke werden ausschließlich unter
den gesichtspunkten effizienz und kosten
entworfen die gestalter des werkes in
kehlen fällt hingegen wollten der
elektrizität einen tempel erbauen
[Musik]
stromerzeugung an sich ist wirklich
simpel man braucht nur etwas
grundlegendes wie eine turbine die einen
magneten innerhalb einer spule antreibt
und das war es schon
aber es sind eine menge dinge nötig um
den strom auch nutzbar zu machen zb
transformatoren oder systeme die dafür
sorgen dass sie die turbinen immer
gleich schnell drehen damit es nicht zu
unterbrechungen kommt
all das musste entwickelt werden und
damals gab es noch nicht die mittel
dafür die menschen dachten sich indianer
strategien aus um wechselstrom nutzbar
zu machen
[Musik]
um strom erzeugen zu können mussten die
riesigen turbinen des kraftwerks von
dampf angetrieben werden in der großen
kessel halle wurden bergeweise kohle und
aber tausende liter wasser aus der nahen
donau bereitgestellt um den prozess in
gang zu setzen
ist raul kohle und wasser erzeugen dampf
und reiben magnete innerhalb von spulen
an wissenschaftlich und physikalisch
gesehen hat sich daran im grunde nichts
verändert wir haben noch keine bessere
art der stromerzeugung gefunden das gilt
auch für atomkraft mit deren hilfe wir
wasser erhitzen und turbinen antreiben
alles dasselbe
ja unsere elektronik hat sich
weiterentwickelt
unsere transformatoren haben sich
weiterentwickelt es gibt weniger schwund
bei der stromverteilung und so weiter
aber im wesentlichen muss man einfach
sagen es hat sich nichts verändert
[Musik]
das kraftwerk erfüllt wurde zu einer
zeit errichtet in der der art déco stil
auch das aussehen von zweckbauten
veränderte das wird vor allem in der
einzigartigen schaltwarte des kraftwerks
deutlich die geschwungenen wände und die
spektakuläre glasdecke zeigen wie viel
aufwand betrieben wurde um die neue
anlage zum vorzeigeobjekt zu machen
lieber robert leitet das nachfolge
kraftwerk von kehlen füllt
[Musik]
mühlenfeld war immer dafür bekannt
neueste technologien zu nutzen und
weiterzuentwickeln
die schaltwarte war die kommandozentrale
des kraftwerks von hier wurden die
elektrischen anlagen kontrolliert
diese technologie die transformatoren
und drehschalter waren in ihrer
ausführung ein novum in europa
die ersten 20 jahre über war das
kraftwerk in aller munde
[Musik]
das war praktisch ein blick in die
zukunft und dabei bediente man sich auch
des designs um die leute zu beeindrucken
das sollte der bevölkerung und der
ganzen welt zeigen wie fortschrittlich
mann war und dass ein neues zeitalter an
brach warum nicht auch das design dafür
nutzen
das neue kraftwerk wurde schon bald zum
vorzeigeobjekt in ungarn und gilt bis
heute als meisterwerk des
industriedesigns
ich finde es großartig dass sie mit dem
art déco stil so in die vollen gingen es
sieht wirklich fantastisch aus
keine ahnung wie gute sich dort arbeiten
ließ wie die akustik darin war und so
was aber design und funktion können auch
hand in hand gehen warum nicht
zwei monate nach inbetriebnahme brachte
erste weltkrieg aus das kraftwerk wurde
in dieser zeit nicht beschädigt mehr als
20 jahre später überstand es auch die
luftangriffe im zweiten weltkrieg die
schöne jugendstil einrichtung bekam in
dieser zeit eine ergänzung im gesamten
kraftwerk wurden dutzende 1 und 2 man
luftschutzräumen errichtet selbst in der
kunstvoll verzierten schaltwarte
[Musik]
die schutzräume entstanden während des
zweiten weltkriegs
glücklicherweise erwiesen sie sich als
überflüssig denn es ging nur eine bombe
nieder und die verfehlte das gebäude
das kraftwerk und das dach wurden nicht
durch bomben beschädigte
[Musik]
einzelnen luft schutzräume mitten in
einer fabrik oder einem industriegebäude
finde ich äußerst verwunderlich
so etwas ist nur tief unter der erde
sinnvoll individuelle bunker mitten im
angriffsziel das ist ziemlich seltsam
es widerspricht auch dem was deutsche
ingenieure in den 20er und 30er jahren
erforscht hatten
sie wollten fabriken so bauen dass im
falle eines luftschlags möglichst wenig
schaden entsteht um die reparatur und
feuer bekämpfungsmaßnahmen möglichst
einfach waren
nach kriegsende blieb die prächtige
jugendstil schaltwarte in betrieb bis
das kraftwerk
2005 nach 91 dienstjahren stillgelegt
und teilweise rückgebaut wurde
[Musik]
am ufer des flusses opfer im westen
russlands steht verlassen ein
einzigartiger stromleitung mast der
sogenannte shoot off mast benannt nach
dem russischen ingenieur vladimir
schuhkauf der hier eine ganz besondere
bauweise anwandte
eine kombination aus kunst und
architektur
[Musik]
der schuhhof mars ist beeindruckend man
sieht ihn an und merkt sofort irgendwas
daran ist anders
der anblick ist verwirrend es scheint
als seien die stahlstreben gebogen dabei
sind sie alle völlig gerade
ein kunstwerk ein meisterwerk der
ingenieurskunst und der mathematik
tatjana wie nokia studiert seit langer
zeit das lebenswerk von vladimir show
auf er war ein ingenieur der die grenzen
der mathematik und der architektur neue
auslotete
[Musik]
sure of war ein großer künstler
manche menschen haben künstlerisches
talent und andere mathematisches talent
aber schuf war sowohl ein brillianter
künstler als auch ein brillianter
ingenieur das war perfekt die
kombination dieser fähigkeiten und
talente machte sein werk erst möglich
der mast hier dient als aufhängung für
stromleitungen damit sie auf der
richtigen höhe bleiben und bis zum
anderen ufer des flusses reichen
insgesamt standen hier sechs dieser
masken 2 am gegenüberliegenden ufer das
etwas höher liegt die restlichen hier am
niedriger gelegenen ufer
auf dem konto sein schuss aufs ansatz
war wirklich bahnbrechend denn viele
solcher masten dienten rein praktischen
zwecken sie mussten eine gewisse höhe
erreichen und sollten einen möglichst
geringen stahlverbrauch haben schoofs
bemühungen gingen aber darüber hinaus er
überlegte wie man sie dabei hübsch
aussehen lassen und sie mathematisch
präzise konstruieren könnte das ergebnis
war eine wunderschöne ungewöhnliche
struktur
[Musik]
dieser schukoff mast war einer von sechs
die ab 1927 errichtet wurden um
stromleitungen über den fluss zu den
wichtigen sowjetischen industrieanlagen
in die stadt nicht nehmen aufgehört zu
führen
neben ihm stand noch ein weiterer
128 meter hoher mast am nordufer des
flusses aber waren schoofs revolutionäre
konstruktionen dem gewicht der
stromleitungen und den scharfen wind an
ihrem ungeschützten standort gewachsen
[Musik]
er musste sicher eine menge berechnungen
anstellen um zu überprüfen ob das ganze
machbar war das designen hüther schlicht
elegant und wirklich schön es wirkt fast
durchsichtig aldi streben sind sehr dünn
so dass der wind relativ problemlos hin
durchziehen kann es ist ein sehr
effizientes wenn auch vielleicht
kompliziert ist dieser
jeder ingenieur der ein mehr als 100
meter hohen turm entwirft muss die
auswirkungen des windes einkalkulieren
da oben kann er auch dann stark sein
wenn es hier unten windstill ist es
würden also kräfte auf den turm für die
er nichts als ein hindernis ist der
eiffelturm zum beispiel ist der recht
massiv gebaut er hat eine große
grundfläche und verjüngt sich nach oben
sieht stabil aus
schoofs bauten sind dagegen viel
graziler irgendwie ist es ihm mit seinem
mathematischen verstand gelungen stabile
bauten zu entwerfen die elegant wirken
aber dabei ihren zweck erfüllen
dort entwickelte sogar eine
bemerkenswerte neuer art seine türme zu
bauen
die art wie hoch aus türme errichtet
wurden ich ziemlich clever sie hätten
die einzelnen segmente neben das
unterste teil stellen und dann darauf
heben können stattdessen haben sie sie
darin fertig gestellt und mussten sie
nur noch hochheben nicht auch noch
seitwärts das hat das ganze sicher
vereinfacht
1896 machte sich schon oft weltweit
einen namen indem er einen wasserturm
mit leichter und gleichzeitig sehr
stabiler streben struktur entwickelte
eine sogenannte hybrid konstruktion
dafür wurden gerade träger auf einem
runden fundament montiert jeder träger
war in einem präzise kalkulierten winkel
zur seite und nach innen geneigt so dass
ein turm entstand der sich nach oben hin
immer weiter verjüngte
er wirkt geboren er hat eine
geschwungene form aber alle einzelteile
sind lang und gerade
wie ermittelt man wie stabil eine
struktur ist wie widerstandsfähig sie
gegenüber winde und ähnlichen ist es ist
verblüffend was er sich dann im fallen
wie es völlig anders als alles was
danach kam er
war ein pionier auf seinem gebiet so
etwas war noch nie da gewesen er konnte
sich auf seine intuition verlassen um
risiken einzuschätzen und sein ziel zu
erreichen
schon oft hatte sein system zwar auch
angewandt um leichtgewichtige tragwerke
für gebäude zu entwerfen aber es war
sein hybrid um design das ihm umgehend
erfolg bescherte über die nächsten 20
jahre baute er rund 200 solcher türme
als nächstes plant schuld auf den bau
eines gewaltigen
350 meter hohen sendeturm es in moskau
aber infolge der russischen revolution
war nicht genügend schnell verfügbar
sodass er sich auf knapp 150 meter
beschränken musste die damals ja wohl
auf karton genannte konstruktion wurde
1922 fertig gestellt und war das erste
größere projekt der jungen russischen
sowjet-republik es festigte zukaufs ruf
als brillianter bautechniker aber wäre
auch sein geplanter riesen turm
umsetzbar gewesen
dieser bau hätte den eiffel turm
überragt er wäre so hoch gewesen wie
drei fußballfelder hintereinander das
muss man sich mal vorstellen
ich bin sicher schuhkauf hätte auch 300
meter höhe bewältigte seine strukturen
war so elegant so unglaublich leicht und
so durchdacht mit all den stahlstreben
die für stabilität sorgten er hätte das
gedacht
würde
[Musik]
auch wenn er dieses vorhaben nie in die
tat umsetzte inspirierte show auf andere
ingenieure seinen design nachzuahmen der
hearst tower in new york und den
londoner bahnhof kings cross sind nur
zwei berühmte bauten die sich an seinem
hybrid stil mit schräg verlaufenden
trägern orientieren schoofs name marco
zutage nur den wenigsten ein begriff
sein aber sein vermächtnis bleibt
bestehen
ende des 19 jahrhunderts war
elektrizität noch eine geheimnisvolle
und fast magische energiequelle
doch innerhalb nicht einmal eines
jahrhunderts wurde sie für große teile
der weltbevölkerung unverzichtbar die
relikte der frühen jahre elektrischer
entwicklung und ihrer bedeutung sowohl
den krebs als auch in friedenszeiten
machen deutlich wie weit die menschheit
seither gekommen ist
nachdem er jahrzehntelang verlassen war
ist es das wort angriff standort zu
neuem leben erweckt worden es gibt pläne
die überreste seines revolutionären
energieversorgungssystems zu erhalten
und sein leben und wirken verstärkt zu
erforschen und zu erfassen
[Musik]
sein leben war so bemerkenswert und er
war so brillant es ist ein jammer dass
uns keine monumente geblieben sind
sondern seine konstruktion praktisch
verschrottet wurde
[Musik]
dank seines abgelegenen standort in der
sperrzone von tschernobyl hat der dura
woodpecker die letzten 30 jahre
überdauert das riesige stählerne
radarsystem ist zu einem eindrücklichen
denkmal der paranoia des kalten krieges
geworden
[Musik]
heutzutage wird der woodpecker wie aus
der zeit gefallen tod und
postapokalyptische
er war mal von größter strategischer
bedeutung und das verleiht ihm
gewissermaßen eine bedrohliche aura
dieses ding hätte den dritten weltkrieg
auslösen können ziemlich imposant
genau wie einst tesla und schulhof noten
heutige ingenieure und wissenschaftler
neu aus was sich mit elektrizität
erreichen und umsetzen lässt
ihre entdeckungen werden eines tages
auch heute noch modernste anlagen in
überholte verlassene ruinen verwandeln
[Musik]